hello and welcome to zero playing GP ray
or g Bray and you don't know ok I'm
going to allow in a bank oh and I have
to climb it and wide a bit recently what
is what what kind of smooth waters there
and probably another big difference to
the and the old main line and just the
trans musician yeah this a form both is
believed to be good for white I think
this is some pretty much consensus
nowadays among theoretical X good that
this type of Van Gogh is actually not
good for black but i'm not an expert I
just know that this is good for white I
don't know exactly why so maybe even
black gum can show me what on black and
can actually get a good game anyway even
though it is not a good opening
variation that is playing as I don't
know the details so I'm going to develop
the bishop and and ok here i'm going to
play b3 i guess i don't think that there
is any tactic here on the long diagonal
and yeah i'm happy to take care of
course yeah this position now is
excellent for it this is just a pawn for
absolutely zilch 92 94 so you can go
Queen d2 here trade queens you I'll do
that training queens should be helpful
in this position
you
his polar age six is hanging so it
cannot even retreat with the Queen
this is basically the idea of that a for
variation to get this kind of locate on
the queenside we're on yeah Black is
just just gone down for nothing for
absolutely nothing I can start to
convert the poor now quite often black
players lose then never take the take on
b5 to get rid of the night but this is
definitely not objectively and correct
my planner is Ruby one king over to d3
and then before to open up for the rooks
and okay I can do that note that this
Bishop is pointing into absolutely thin
air I it doesn't do anything and yeah
okay now I'm going before definitely
when he after his king went on the C
file
either the only old bank on Main Line
has a very dodgy reputation nowadays
because of that a for variation and um
yeah games like like this are the reason
why of course black can play play better
but we see how problematic it can get
okay um let's see it's not so easy to
defend a 4 here right look here no but I
can do that right I cook back okay 897
look a four is working and no it
actually isn't I can do that and I can
do that
look a four-night the edge Roxy for I
have to check here on the background and
maybe here as well night a 60 X check on
be aid King be seven as possible but
this is not bad right at threatening 96
and deluca's hanging so this should be
quite good his rook is hanging and I'm
threatening 96 so you should lose on the
exchange at least yeah he he did lose
the exchange what about this now is
there some way to finish him off check
check to these six dozen centers and
when immediately so check perhaps I
absolutely have time you know there's no
no need to rush with anything check okay
so checking their doesn't help even
though is this king is somewhat under
pressure I can go to g ade yeah it's
actually quite good and now that's
that's a decent way to play and i also
have rook rook to see to to see aid yeah
this is actually stronger threatens
check made and
ok
I could move I didn't I should have
played that differently didn't want to
give up before here absolutely not okay
I don't like how I played this this is
this is absolutely bad technical play
check time warning Burke check check
turn the whole here ok probably get that
square on g4 check and
playing this badly as I just do
and then far too slow in the process
really really awful really awful winning
position out of the open and then you
stumble in its simple ending check check
and check check check check check check
and check late okay how was a bit lucky
that I managed that time was at the end
I actually think it was winning the
whole time but I just I just made it so
difficult from a position where I had
total control it was pretty awful so
okay I think the main thing is that this
move water is just just no good I think
t6d 6cm you basically are forced to go
into the old main line with bishop in 6
and this I believe is currently and yeah
questionable for black after eight for
Queenie to it seems that white has a
very good game and the way he played it
it is exactly the way how wide wants it
to be yeah yeah I've got absolute
control over the queenside the play is
completely frozen night comes over to
see for here we even had the Kree trade
and frontier this is a winning position
you just have to have to play well
technically and I didn't I mean this was
okay up
to this point even before and he
stumbled into that and now it should be
a really clean affair and maybe me
distance is a complete win why what was
certificate him chan ok I think it was
okay up to here Jack's air for was good
maybe this is running around there with
the rooks and was kind of a kind of sub
sub yeah yeah it was good jack chen me
is still like plus three the computer
that actually doesn't really mind what
I'm doing and but it felt usually
unnecessary again no the pawns the H
porn can run a check young and I'm
promoting here yeah maybe it was okay
but it didn't feel like a very smooth
and technical part of the game really
didn't ok I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching